secretary Kerry first of all thank you
so much for doing this it's an honor to
be here with you historically the State
Department has focused on diplomacy as a
means of creating a more stable world
what's changed over the last 10 or 20
years that's made exporting
entrepreneurship such a priority well
from the day that I was nominated I have
consistently said that that that foreign
policy is economic policy and economic
policy is foreign policy and we are
living we all know the word it word has
become almost right a globalized
community it's a small world everybody's
in touch with everybody things move so
rapidly and there's huge competition for
market share and so forth so it's a
world in which you better be ahead of
the game in creating jobs creating the
new technologies and staying ahead of
the curve it's that simple and it is
vital to creating stability making peace
if you don't have jobs for tens of
millions of young people in many of
these countries we're in trouble and
it's the entrepreneurs who create the
job ten years ago the President or the
Secretary of State a summit like this is
entrepreneurship a vehicle for democracy
it can be certainly I think in terms of
communication and speed you know the
freedom to invest the nature of
risk-taking tends to want openness that
I think it works more effectively but
it's not exclusive to that know there
are raging the capitalist enterprises
going on in authoritarian governments in
countries with authoritarian governments
I mean China as an example it's a
one-party system it's an authoritarian
government and it is competing
voraciously around the world so but I
think China has some challenges because
of its internet policy and and and the
nature of risk-taking there and the
nature of the partnerships required and
some things I think there's a certain
limitation in it in the long run does
Donald Trump threaten what President
Obama has built when it comes to
entrepreneurship when it comes well I
I'm not look I it's not my job and roll
to get into the middle of the election
that people will make their judgments I
have said and I and I repeat that
everywhere I go people are asking me
about his statements and they are
expressing great concern but the
candidates have to fight that out one of
the greatest entrepreneurs in the world
Mark Zuckerberg was recently
photographed with a shot of his laptop
but you could see it in the background
he had tape over the camera and tape
over the microphone what does that say
about the state of cybersecurity in this
world well cybersecurity is a challenge
if you're not aware of what you're doing
and saying and what sort of apps you
have a telephone can be a listening
device as well as a communications
device and that and a camera and the
camera can work different ways so people
obviously need to be aware we are
working very very hard with countries to
establish the norms and to have rules of
the road with respect to cyber we made
progress with China to some degree we're
still working at the implementation but
it is a challenge and we all in
government are particularly sensitized
and careful former attorney General Eric
Holder recently said he now believes
Edward Snowden did a public service by
exposing surveillance techniques
exposing this debate do you do you agree
well I mean I'm uncomfortable saying
it's a public service because I think he
exposed secrets about intelligence
gathering and intelligence work that
puts Americans and people in the world
at risk so you can look and say well I'm
glad we know about these things more but
it shouldn't have happened that way and
he did it with a recklessness that has
put lives at risk and I'm not
comfortable with that and never will be
in the standoff that arose between Apple
and the FBI over
Bernardino shooters iPhone the FBI
ultimately fairly quickly when they have
employed the help of the private sector
found a workaround to get into that
phone do you still believe there is
clear government interest in requiring
back doors on you know encrypted
technologies by us technology where
where there is a legitimate probable
cause there's no reason that that
information is more protected than other
kinds of records and records that people
have and keep which is subject to lawful
subpoena and lawful availability where
it meets the standard of probable cause
with respect to our judicial system and
that's why we have separate branches of
government because they act
independently but I invite people you
know people need to go back 20 years and
examine what kind of privacy we had 20
years ago you could buy criminal records
of people on publicly you can get bank
records finance records mortgage Bay i
mean there's an incredible amount of
loss of privacy has taken place long
before the internet actually came into
being people were subject to but they
just didn't know about it as much so i
think people have to be aware of the
threats that we face in the world today
i think our government has been
remarkably remarkably faithful to our
fundamental beliefs and to our rights
and has been very careful to require
standards to require judicial review to
acquire different protections in order
to secure people's rights and freedom
and i'm proud of that i mean as i think
about it we've gone overboard in many
many different ways in order to limit
the intrusiveness but at the same time
protect the American people and I will
say to you blood lee that there are any
number in the double digits of plots
that have been interrupted where many
lives might have been lost were it not
for our ability to be able to take
massively gathered not individual but
massively gathered and analyzed
information and make sense out of it one
last question and anonymously gathered I
add um Boober and Airbnb have been the
breakout technology companies of this
decade but I've run into a host of
regulatory issues around the world how
do you balance local interest with the
relentless rise of a new technology well
that's always going to happen that's
what makes it exciting I mean that's
that's kind of fun in a way look this
has always been true i mean when you
know cotton gins came along and when we
first had the steam engines and
everything's over the years different
standards began to be applied as people
learned more about what the danger or
threat or downside of these things are
and that's why we have rules and laws
about tobacco or about lead paint or any
number of things seat belts in cars
Ralph Nader and the whole you know
development of those standards there's
always going to be a tension in that
it's going to be a yin and yang of pull
and a tug from interests on the ground
that want the protection and from people
who want the freedom to just go to what
they do and and it finds its balance I
think it finds an equilibrium and people
in the United States of America are a
hell of a lot safer today than they were
25 years ago 50 years ago 100 years ago
live longer as a result left less
injuries in the workplace all kinds of
benefits that have come so it works its
way out in the end secretary Kerry thank
you so much